الى جانب قوى المعارضه وكفنواب التغيير
بعد ثمانيه اشهر من الفشل في توحيد الصف
العدو واحد نظام بوليسي شدد قبضته على
القضاء وحول اهالي ضحايا المرفق الى
مطلوبين وساهم في تكريس شهور سده الرئاسه
تطورات دراماتيكيه شهدها لبنان خلال
الايام الماضيه جمعت المعارضه لاول مره في
بيان موحد بعد ان اصطف النواب المعارضون
خلف تحركات الشارع ومطالب من يمثلون في
مشهد مغير لخلافاتهم التي عاهدها
اللبنانيون تحت قبه البالومه
مع بعضنا بالقطعه لانه عم بيهجمونا عم
بيهجمونا بالجمله
لذلك نحن اليوم ما عم نطلب انه همم
وحدنا امبارح لدعم القضاء ودعم ضحايا
اهالي الانفجار المعرفه احنا اليوم همم
كيف يقولوا نستصرخ ضمائر رفاقنا بالسيادين
بالمعارضه انه يقربوا لنا ندعم مرشح 45
نيئه
بالملف الرئاسي موحدين دستوريا بالكامل
الموضوع قضيه التفجير وبينما تحاول
المعارضه لبناء على قواسم مشتركه يحاول
حزب الله اصلاح ما افسدته حرب الرئاسه مع
التيار الوطني الحر
ارسال وفد من صفوفه الاولى للقاء جبران
باسيل حليفي تحالف مارم خيل اتاك محاوله
لانقاذ الاتفاق الذي بات مهددا بعد ان
خرجت خلافه الطرفين الى العلم
بدون ما تستفيد منه لانه باي لحظه سياسيه
معينه ممكن نرجع نشوف جبران بصير اعيد الى
بيت الطاعه بين الاوسين عند حزب الله
ساعات بيختلف الوضع داخل مجلس النواب
وباصوات الرئاسيه ولاحقا بالتكليف الحكومي
وتشكيله الحكوميه
لا شك ان الانتخابات الاخيره زعزعت قدره
حزب الله وحلفائه داخل المجلس النيابي لكن
المعارضه لم تستفيد من اتساع ركعتها رغم
القواسم مشتركه قد تبني عليها في المستقبل
توصلت الاحزاب المعارضه الى ضروره توحيد
الصفوف بعد اشهر من التشرزم خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالاستحقاقات الوطنيه اليوميه وصولا
الى انتخابات رئيس الجمهوريه غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت